on this episode of Imagine a world I
think um optimism is very much
associated with a certain kind of has to
be crude stereotyping here a certain
kind of Silicon Valley libertarianism
and I think that has given optimism a
bad name among certain people because
it's a very monolithic Vision but I
would like to see a kind of more
pluralistic visions of how AI can make
the world a better place or how the
future could be better better than the
present
welcome to imagine a world a mini series
from the future of Life Institute this
podcast is based on a contest we ran to
gather ideas from around the world about
what a more positive future might look
like in 2045
we hope the diverse ideas you're about
to hear will spark discussions and maybe
even collaborations but you should know
that the ideas in this podcast are not
to be taken as f-aligned or positions
and now over to our host Guillaume
reason
[Music]
welcome to the imagine a world podcast
by the future of Life Institute I'm your
host Guillaume reason
in this episode we'll be exploring a
world called core Central which was a
second place winner of fli's World
building contest
in this world Humanity becomes unified
under a single World Government
supported by a Fantastical artificial
intelligence Network known as the core
system
this system is spread fractally along
societal lines with components
representing different countries and
communities and even smaller ones
interacting with individuals
its Global reach forms a kind of social
exoskeleton that helps to support all
manner of human flourishing
the core structure is centralized and
monolithic but also contains a huge
range of diverse and semi-independent
components
this forms a paradoxical network of
intelligence that really challenges our
Notions of agency and individuality
other changes in this world such as
increased life spans empathy building
Technologies and personalized education
are also richly explored
there's a deep sense of enduring
complexity throughout
thorny issues of justice and well-being
remained thorny despite technological
and economic progress
this is a world unified despite or maybe
thanks to its engagement with all manner
of difficult conversations between
individuals and communities
this world was created by a team of
seven hailing from the University of
Cambridge in England
they were our largest winning team with
a wide range of expertise spanning
ethics cognitive science policy and
infrastructure our first guests today
are John Burton and Henry shevlin who
are both on the more philosophical side
of things
later in the episode we also get to hear
from laramani who studies the effective
communication of existential risks her
work is so relevant to this competition
so make sure you stick around for that
there are four other team members were
abidus abralick Jessica Bland Clarissa
Rios Rojas and Catherine Richards
so hi John and Henry thanks for joining
us
it's a pleasure to be here yeah likewise
so you're one of the biggest teams that
we had in our top 10 there's seven of
you how did all seven of these folks
come together to work on this submission
together
also we're uh coming from two distinct
centers
um uh like sibling senses the leaving
him sense the future of intelligence
um the center of the study of
existential risk both of which are based
in the same building in Cambridge and
have lots of overlapping projects but I
think that meant there was a big pool of
potential researchers to draw on so that
was the first part yeah I think quite a
few of us were perhaps interested in
uh maybe entering individually or in
smaller groups but we sort of wound up
uh Lara decided one of the one of our
other team members she decided to see if
anyone wanted to do like a joint Caesar
CFI submission and we kind of just met
and and evolved from there that's cool
so multiple of you it sounds like had
come across the contest but Lara was
kind of the um the nucleation site that
kind of brought you all together the cat
heard her who got us all uh it got us
all in in order that's cool that makes
sense since my understanding is Lara
studies risk communication and what
makes it effective and has done stuff
like role-playing activities and like
scenario based exercises that involve
like group work in that way yeah
so you two have this kind of academic
perspective where John is looking at
like the AI risk and power assessment
among other things and Henry you're
looking at you know consciousness of AI
and creativity and these other
measurements there's two other people
that I kind of when I was going through
your team sort of classified on the more
academic side there's Biba who's a
philosophy PhD student studying like
ethics for emerging Tech and online
influence efforts and then there's Lara
who I mentioned who is studying like
ways of communicating risk would you
guys agree with that kind of
categorization where you're kind of the
more academic perspective and then
there's kind of a more policy or
engineering side anything I'd quibble
with there is you know the term academic
we're all academics in a way
I guess I mean more theoretical perhaps
right right exactly yeah that's that's
exactly right how was it to work with
the team of this size
at first it was immense fun right uh and
I think that's one reason we managed to
keep the team together
um because you know with seven people uh
seven busy sort of relatively early
early career academics you know we all
have way too much to do
um but actually most of us showed up for
most sessions you know we all came into
the project with our own angles and we
very much at least in the initial phase
kind of worked on our own bits there was
a lot of subdivision of stuff and then
sort of the latter part of it was
figuring out how to make it all gel
together and I think one of the
consequences of that is it made it feel
more realistic there isn't um there
isn't sort of one overriding narrative
there's not a single clean story it's a
very hard world to sum up in like uh
some some up in a in a sentence yeah and
I think I think that makes that's yeah
partly because there's it's almost like
simulating a kind of stochastic element
when you have so many different authors
kind of contributing their own things
and then figuring out how to make it
play nicely together that's my
experience what do you think Joe I think
I think you're you're right there I mean
first of all yeah it was very fun
um and a lot of the time we were having
these conversations you know we were
meeting up to do the World building
together and we would just get chatting
and not really for for quite a long time
not actually make any progress because
we were just enjoying chatting about
these different things and where things
might lead and so on and then the
deadline starts looming and when we have
to start like actually writing things
down
um but yeah with with seven with seven
people all having a lot of ideas and
also very different views of of the
world and maybe even like what desirable
AI could look like or what the most you
know the biggest priorities for using it
should be so it sounds like this is a
really like kind of intensely
collaborative discussion based process
for you which is really cool to hear
and I do think you do feel that I agree
that you have this kind of naturalness
in the world you know the way it kind of
goes all these different directions and
all these different factors are going on
and one thing I really appreciate is how
many interesting little Corners you kind
of dive into and sketch out like
discussions or conflicts that are
happening like things people in the
world are arguing about and I can see
now how that might come from side
discussions you had where you kind of
spun off into this and we're like I
guess they'd have to figure that out in
this world themselves you know
[Music]
this world explores many parallel
threads from global scale standoffs
involving lethal autonomous weapons to
anti-aging drugs companion Robo Butlers
and even artificially intelligent
Facebook friends there's a bustle and a
chaos to it that feels believable
the team put a lot of thought into
imagining how these changes are
experienced by different individuals and
societies and I wanted to hear some of
John and Henry's ideas on what life
might actually be like in this shifting
world that they helped to imagine
[Music]
so one one major feature of your world
is this commitment to centralization and
this is both in terms of how AI
Technologies are developed but also in
terms of how governments are functioning
over time they kind of join together
could you describe how a person in your
world would experience both of these
types of centralization
so
one of the the ways that things are set
up in our world are that a lot of the
political unions such as the EU have
sort of federalized to some larger
extent than they are now
uh and you know the similar thing has
happened in South America and in Africa
and this sort of originated as like a
trading block because you know we're
getting to this globalized state where
having a sort of trading block is quite
important but this sort of really came
to a head when in the last few years
from our world's perspective the AI sort
of Court Central that we uh have
envisaged winds up becoming far more
integrated in in governments and and
such around the world mostly just
because of the natural advantages that
it's that it's able to bring but what
this winds up having an effect is this
sort of um
almost like an unintentional cooperation
going on right like this AI system is
sort of able to
um you know it's sort of acting in such
a way that's beneficial for all of its
sort of constituent uh sort of countries
that are involved but it's sort of aware
that it's sort of involved in other
nations as well right and so it's sort
of trying to bring together and make
choices that are sort of Equitable and
um helpful for all of the sort of
countries that have sort of onboarded
this uh or sort of integrated this into
the decision-making processes and this
kind of has a Snowball Effect right
because other countries that haven't
initially not opted into this sort of
see oh wow hold on this is actually
quite useful and they sort of wind up
joining it as well
um and I think at the very end of our
timeline is the point where the
countries are sort of about to have a
vote
on whether they should actually just
form a single world polity and sort of
have a merge of all the countries but at
that point it's not something that's
happened yet
yeah um I guess from the perspective of
a person living right it like with the
rest of the world it's sort of a very um
the world is in a lot of change there's
a lot of change towards and flux and you
know you can see this this is quicker
than maybe most people would see
political change in their lifetime as we
normally know it I I imagine it would be
quite exciting but also maybe a little
bit intimidating yeah who do you think
would most benefit from or be threatened
by each of these types of centralization
like as an individual I understand why
this would happen at a larger scale but
like what would it be like to see your
nation kind of be absorbed into this
larger thing is that like a hopeful
thing or a scary thing yeah I think it
it depends right
um in in a sense it could potentially be
better or worse depending on your
current sort of I guess standing in the
global world uh in terms of economy or
whatever you know because you kind of if
you're a smaller Nation you maybe have
this hopeful assurance that your uh
wishes are going to be represented and
that the current system will work for
you whereas I guess if you're one of the
more traditionally prestigious Nations
that has a history of trying to look
good or whatever I'm not entirely the
word has escaped me here yeah um those
which have enjoyed more power
historically yeah yeah exactly exactly
if you're if you're uh from one of these
then you maybe stand to lose your
relative position in in some arbitrary
hierarchy yeah I guess also on a sort of
more personal level leaders of certain
Nations might realize that their current
style of government or something is not
particularly well suited to the new uh
transition that is that is maybe coming
up
um obviously things like dictators and
so on are probably going to lose out if
this is something that happens right if
you go from having you know unchecked
power in a relatively small area of the
world to
oh okay that's just not a thing anymore
then obviously you then have something
to lose
um but I guess you know obviously the
the populations of these countries and
you know in general are probably going
to benefit from this yeah
and what about the centralization of the
AI technology like do you imagine any
individuals struggling with the fact
that kind of all the AI technology
becomes part of this core system yeah so
I think this is where we maybe have to
be a bit careful about what we talk when
we talk about AI technology right so I'm
sure that a lot of the technology that
we are beginning to see now you know
what is comparatively basic to uh type
of Technology that's in the world you
know the chat gpts the assistance the
image recognition
I think that's all still going to be you
know available right
um maybe there are certain limits on
misuse maybe there is more regulation
from things that we're seeing nowadays
like the EU AI act and so on but it's
this more sort of General AGI that is
sort of more uh centralized and I think
that with the type of AGI that we've
imagined which is very sort of agentic
right like it can take actions in the
real world it's trying to
um in better the lives of of humanity
and help with flourishing I think that
having two of those that may be trying
to optimize slightly different things
could be potentially a problem in the
future so yeah whether or not the normal
people sort of just trying to get on
with their lives are super aware of this
is is a different question there's
probably going to be some pushback from
you know the tech companies and so on
who are now saying well why can't we
make one of these things yeah right
um and I think that's something that has
to be handled with you know proper
Outreach and so on in in this world
um
well you mentioned this issue of
potentially having two and how they
could Clash does that imply that you
kind of see the single AGI centralized
model as necessary to having a good
outcome for the development of AGI so I
think I think it really depends again on
on
um what exactly what type of systems
we're talking about so if we're talking
about something that's sort of like an
agendic AGI then very small differences
in say uh value preferences you know
could potentially lead to Big
disagreements the same way that we see
countries in you know in the real world
disagreeing over over things and
eventually going to war yeah and I think
that seeing or sort of imagining an AGI
as an entity that you know may have
these preferences and and it's sort of
comparatively more powerful than than
most human entities or organizations or
whatever
you know we don't want Humanity to
become stuck in the middle of some tiny
you know some uh some power struggle for
for the you know
who can help Humanity the best right
right so even if both of them are trying
to do things that are good you know
there might be a slight preference for
one thing over another which if you're
then optimizing in some super
intelligent way could still become you
know a point of contention yeah
and in terms of the sort of governmental
structure do you see the eventual
potential unification of the whole globe
as kind of like a victory for Humanity
like something we've achieved with the
help of AI or do you see it as something
that is sort of necessary to survive the
existence of these powerful Technologies
this is a tricky question right because
I think there are ways in which this
could be tremendously helpful but also
ways in which this could be sort of
tremendously risky we also have to
consider that we're not only dealing in
a world where AGI is the only threat
there's also other sort of threats to
humanity such as climate change nuclear
war and so on and I think that having a
sort of centralized structure can help
you make decisions that are sort of
without the risk of falling into tragedy
of the common situation but it also
definitely opens up problems in terms of
potential totalitarianism if things
aren't done appropriately and I mean
maybe this is where the AI can sort of
help keep us in check and we can sort of
help keep it in check with the sort of
hopefully neatly bow balanced system of
I guess checks and balances on on each
of them in terms of alignment but also
in terms of the AI sort of helping us to
keep the worst aspects of humanity sort
of in check I guess
yeah
so one other thing that we really should
touch on is the structure of AGI in your
world because it is really kind of
unique and alien you have this really
branched thing which is all arguably one
system but kind of at its limits
presents itself as varyingly distinct
sub-components you have these like
avatars that sort of have embodied you
know entities themselves but are also in
constant communication with core Central
can you explain a little bit more about
how how this whole system works
yeah so so at a very high level core
Central is sort of the uh the organizing
component of the the AGI system
and it oversees sort of a vast array of
other core systems uh which are often
you know delegated a particular task or
you know maybe relating to to health or
to uh the economy or to education or to
particular continents and so on and
there's sort of a sort of hierarchical
distribution of tasks going down uh sort
of mirroring a sort of tree in a way but
there's also sort of communication
between different cores sort of trying
to come to mutual agreements about
how exactly you know the sort of thing
they need from each other and how they
you know how they should be interacting
yeah so a lot of these systems will be
sort of distributed uh throughout
various places in the world right and
this this introduces a lot of uh
potential latency you know which for for
very intelligent AGI systems becomes you
know almost agonizingly slow and so
there's sort of a necessity for there to
be like a higher level of sort of
decentralized you know autonomy if you
will and so we kind of came up with this
sort of separated
um you know I think my biggest
inspiration for this was like octopuses
octopus octopets actor codes
you know they have a lot of sort of
almost parts of their brain in their in
their tentacles right yeah 40 I think is
the figure and I guess my my idea was
something about what if what if this but
but on a much bigger scale where the
tentacles are sort of you know still
more intelligent than humans but they're
sort of still you know there they're
receiving this communication from a sort
of even greater intelligence but still
have a lot of remit to act among
themselves
yeah so this tree of intelligence these
like tentacles kind of grow along the
lines of society to support all the
different factions and groups of humans
that are on the planet but I wonder if
they're all one thing like how how do
they support these individual groups of
people like countries for example the
way we currently understand them when
they might kind of have differing
interests like is there a sense of
loyalty to the parts of the world that
they're focused on yeah so this is this
is an interesting question and I'm not
sure exactly
how to go about answering it right
because I think core Central and the
core system as a whole is is still
constantly looking forwards right it's
trying to sort of nudge the world to be
in a more unified place right with this
idea of sort of reducing inequality
breaking down sort of arbitrary barriers
that don't really serve any purpose and
so maybe some of these actions that it's
taking while initially unpopular perhaps
might be sort of nudging society into
sort of accepting the more long-term
view of this
hmm I'm also um uh struck by so I also
love octopuses and so that's one reason
and I you know I love this model
um but I think you know even at the
level of the human brain I um and you
know I'm not going to take too much of a
detour into Neuroscience of
Consciousness here but um I I think we
have this very alluring image of an
entirely unified conscious experience
but it's very hard to make sense of that
when you actually look at neural
processes so one view in the science of
Consciousness that I'm very attracted to
is something called Global workspace
Theory which basically says there is
kind of a central Clearing House an
executive part of the brain probably
your prefrontal cortex
um that basically uh negotiates uh
differences between different parts of
your brain and sets a a central policy
um and that so that's sort of what your
Consciousness is according to Global
workspace Theory and so I immediately
saw some interesting uh analogies
between that and the kind of
organization that we were we were laying
out there and it seemed a really natural
way to organize a complex intelligence
yeah and this can go wrong my background
is also a neuroscience slash cognitive
science and like you know there's alien
hand syndrome like some people will end
up in a situation where part of their
body seems to be behaving in a way that
is opposed to their sense of control so
you can kind of have these opposing
systems suddenly revealed
famously Dr Strangelove right the
classic cinematic illustration of this
yeah but yeah I guess I guess that is
one of the ways in which this could you
know in our world at least go wrong is
that one of these say cause goes Rogue
right and I think that's what one of the
big organizations in our world the
preservation and Alignment organization
is is sort of there for right like
monitoring some of the sub cores making
sure that they are remaining aligned
remaining in sort of communication
you know to ensure that this sort of
thing doesn't happen to ensure that none
of the cores sort of do a kernel Kurtz
go and go go wild lose lose touch with
Central Command
yeah
[Music]
maybe the biggest story in this world if
you zoom out is the unification of
humanity
by 2043 all World governments have
Incorporated the core system into their
workings the strange paradoxical
structure of the core system seems to
make this possible
cores each Fray out into bespoke
components they can connect with and
support every different human culture
while still maintaining this centralized
sense of control
in this world that centralization seems
to be the key to keeping Global Systems
both artificial and human from
catastrophic conflicts
I wanted to hear more about the
potential benefits and drawbacks of this
kind of centralization and how it came
to be
so early on in your world there is a
number of kind of runaway AI scares and
they they push us to research control
alignment and explainability in
different ways that we can ensure these
systems are actually going to do what we
want them to do could you briefly
describe like what one of those runaway
scares would have looked like
I'm reminded as well of this uh
interesting Tom Scott video from from a
few years ago where it's like a
hypothetical scenario where some
copyright company is sort of developing
an AI to try and identify you know the
sort of thing uh the automated copyright
that you sort of see on on YouTube and
the idea is that it will sort of
automatically detect uh when music is
being played that hasn't got the the
appropriate rights whatever and it will
sort of go and remove it automatically
but it sort of it comes to some
realization that there is a lot of
unlicensed music going around in
people's heads right and so so it starts
developing and becoming more General to
the point where it starts uh just
harmlessly removing it from people's
heads so like there's no like giant
apocalypse but like a whole a whole
Century almost a few Decades of music
just winds up disappearing from people's
memory
um and then it takes the sort of the
traditional sort of
AGI you know self-protection uh
precautions to stop to stop it from
being you know removed and so on and and
you know life goes on but there's just
this giant amount of time missing and
I'm actually sort of invisible barriers
around Humanity that they aren't really
aware of now I feel like my memory of
this conversation is going to disappear
well so I think we should clarify one
thing as we're talking about AIS versus
agis we've been talking about like chat
Bots and things like that which are in
in our world right now kind of you know
based on these multi-layer neural
networks and similar Technologies of
just like large data but in your world
you have this clear distinction where
the AGI like the really fancy smarter
than human in most ways stuff comes
about from a different thread of
technology which begins with full brain
simulation so can you say a little bit
about that yeah so when when writing
this I kind of wanted to make it make
sure that um
it's not reliant on just being an
extension of what we have but but bigger
right
um but neither is it also something
completely different
um so the idea I had initially was not
necessarily sort of simulating an entire
person's brain but figuring out the
general connective structure of say the
human mind and trying to build an
architecture based on that rather than
necessarily like uploading someone into
into a computer the idea is to use it
more as like a base architecture that
can be somehow trained and aligned and
and evolved from there yeah well one
thing that you are able to do in your
world because of this like simulation
origin of AGI is develop uh intent
analysis so I take that as like a way to
just guarantee that you know what this
system is trying to do can you say a
little about that because for me intent
is is squishy in a way in that it seems
like a narrative that an agent has about
itself and could be misleading or or not
the whole story like how does this give
us real security
yeah so this is this is interesting I
mean this is going off of um
I think it's Paul Cristiano's sort of
definition of alignment where it's not
necessarily that the agent is going to
perfectly do what we ask every time but
it's at least gonna try right and it's
this trying to do the right thing that
we wanted to capture with intent
analysis and kind of just
I hope that the capabilities take us the
rest of the way
and I think this is something that
obvious obviously the um
the technical specifications for intent
alignment aren't aren't here right now
otherwise we might we might well already
have AGI
um and so actually talking about it in
detail is is quite tricky but the idea
is that you can sort of figure out some
way of trying to understand what the AI
system is is intending to do
and obviously there are there are many
ways this might fail right through
something like self-deception uh where
the where the AGI is is intentionally
deceiving itself to intend to do
something but it gets it gets very messy
and it's yeah yeah or like the story you
just told I mean you could say that that
system was just trying to remove
copyrighted music from people's thoughts
is it really means well it's trying to
protect the creators they need their
money like they should get Kickbacks
yeah so I think the idea with this
intent uh alignment was more about
finding out the intention of of their
specific actions that are like going to
be used to achieve this goal right
rather than just what goal it is
intending to achieve but sort of a plan
for how it is going to uh achieve this
right and that does give you a bit more
of a concrete idea about what the risks
might be you know if this copyright AI
said under some intent analysis oh I
intend to go into everyone's brain and
start zapping out the neurons that are
responsible for this you go no I don't
want you to do that yeah and I think
it's it's that sort of predictability
that becomes important for guaranteeing
safety with regards to these sort of
powerful AI systems yeah so one of the
things that alignment you know suggests
as well is that there's sort of dangers
of this in in the it sort of
incentivizes what they call like
deceptive alignment right where there's
this idea that the AI sort of pretends
to be aligned until it's sure right and
so this idea about sort of constantly
keeping it guessing about whether it's
in a test sort of relies on you actually
being able to convincingly do that to
some entity that may well be like
smarter than you well so this is
obviously an incredibly thorny issue I
mean the whole concept of alignment
itself is thorny and complicated you
know there's a lot of moral questions
there about like who it's aligned to and
stuff but in your world one of the main
ways that this is all kind of managed is
through the preservation and Alignment
organization Pao which is like the first
social institution that AI created and
it's a big collaborative effort I think
there's like like 10 000 humans and a
bunch of you know portions of this AI
system all working together to try to
ensure that nothing goes sideways
basically but I was curious like what
happens if something does go sideways
like if we're going back to thinking
this is like a big kind of octopus tree
sort of alien thing you know say that
one of the cores is discovered to be
misaligned is it kind of amputated or
what do you do about that I mean I mean
first before we before we go into that I
think one thing that is important to
like highlight is that this uh the
preservation of an alignment
organization can only sort of keep
things running along right like it can't
be responsible for the initial alignment
right so whatever your goal is as an AI
system you have an incentive to keep it
the same right right this sort of idea
about uh you don't let people come along
and change your utility function
and the reason for this is that it it
stops you being able to do whatever your
current goal is because it would change
what you liked someone's kind of like an
immune system in a way where like you
know the whole system is functioning but
there might be these local areas that
get out of control kind of similar to
cancer or something and and they get
squashed out yeah exactly but I guess if
something were to go wrong right I guess
core Central would probably treat it
like some kind of cancer as you say
right like this idea that okay this one
aspect of the AI has has
uh started going out of control and it
just has to be sort of uh removed yeah
well so this is really leaning into this
centralization as being vital and we're
talking about these these variations of
intent as like cancers and bad things
but you could also Imagine you know
maybe one of the cores like starts to
get a new intent which is like to
develop the most beautiful music and
this is like a relatively harmful thing
but it would be squashed in your world
because it's no longer aligned is there
a concern here of like losing some
potential for diversity or or dynamism
in the system if it's so focused on
preservation and alignment
yeah I mean I guess that sort of concern
is always there when you have these sort
of very large almost monolithic systems
they become Static slow and and
resistant to change
but I feel like in this instance at
least this sort of becomes
um almost our fault at the outset for
encoding alignment from a sort of human
perspective right um and so one of the
things that was most important to us
when making AGI in this world was making
sure that humans don't die out and
that's obviously still incredibly
important
you know in in 2045 five years after HEI
but we never sort of included a value
for the AI right
um and so I guess it's sort of almost
logically extends the core Central would
have no real issue Maybe
with removing part of itself and
destroying it yeah I mean maybe there's
a better solution right like maybe maybe
there's the option to become a different
core
um and this is obviously something that
the core Central and the corals would
have to sort of decide for themselves
right like maybe there's some uh core
devoted to education that now wants to
be making a massive nice Garden maybe
there's you know a new role that can
open up to sort of handle this
but I guess at the end of the day it's
also a question about
why has this misalignment occurred right
and and is this something that could
lead to sort of much worse situations
other than just doing a different job
right you know like if you could Drift
from education to gardening how does uh
sort of big AGI still have the assurance
that you're not going to drift from
gardening to uh murder right
I think I mean what you've said really
gets to this core problem that I think
you know people are also discussing just
abstractly about alignment in general
which is like who is it aligned with
like you're saying it's aligned with
humans being preserved and that maybe
leaves out the AIS it also leaves out
other sentient beings or or you know
animals or maybe other aliens that might
exist in the world
so there is there is this kind of focus
that's built in at the beginning
yeah and I think that's something that's
going to be very tricky
for
human or Humanity to do in in you know
in the real world over the next however
long until we have AGI yeah
so I'm curious to explore the path
towards this kind of Monolithic
centralization that your world ends up
going towards basically every country
eventually incorporates core Central
into their administrations I think by
2043 like that's already happened and
this is just due to the huge benefits
and incentives of doing that can you
describe some of those benefits and
incentives
yeah I mean I mean the most obvious one
to me is the benefits that core Central
or the core system brings can lead to
sort of almost objectively or
demonstratively better
standards of living for your people
right and as a leader it's very hard to
try and go against that particularly in
the in the short term yeah um and this
is sort of just how I imagine things
naturally going if you have these giant
monolithic AI systems where if you do
include it then you're going to benefit
massively and your neighbors who haven't
are not and I think that there's a
there's a a bit of a power disparity
here that I'm still not sure how I feel
about this part of our work right
so for my part I would add that um when
it comes to economics I think capitalism
is a very flawed system but it's the
least flawed one we've come across so
far
um because you know the Invisible Hand
and uh and price signals are very useful
uh I think their capitalism has brought
many many benefits and global capitalism
in particular but so many Industries it
just creates awful incentives so
um one of the things that I would hope
is that AGI could uh of course Central
could help countries outperform
capitalism in terms of economic
efficiencies
yeah this also gets back to that
question of the world improving in ways
that are measurable but not ways that
are unmeasurable and one of the little
kind of side discussions that you sketch
out happening in your world is This
Global conversation about the
quantifiability of human Goods like
you're using these AI systems to analyze
legislation see what kinds of changes
you might roll out across your
population but what is actually
available to you to measure like can you
actually tell if people are fulfilled
whatever that means and how do you avoid
over indexing on on easy to measure
factors like GDP or other things like
that yeah I mean at a high level this
this rule goes back to sort of trying to
avoid pitfalls from say good Hospital
right like the idea that once you once
you stop measuring
anything and you start using it for
optimization then all of a sudden uh
almost measuring the wrong thing your
measures ceases to be useful in a way
and I think that's something that's very
difficult to escape
but my my hope is that by sort of taking
in so many things into account you can
sort of almost out proxy the proxy in a
way right like sort of Escape that trap
yeah
both Utopias and dystopias often feature
highly centralized societies of course
Central doesn't shy away from some of
the more frightening aspects of
unification and surveillance but its
portrayal is overall aspirational
I wanted to take some time to explore
how this colorful messy World pushes
back against dystopian narratives and to
hear about the other positive stories
that may have inspired it
so I'd like to transition to talking
about how some of the popular portrayals
that people might be familiar with
um
of our future relate to what you've
imagined and one thing in particular
that I'm curious about is
decentralization issue your world goes
really hard on this direction of
centralization it's kind of this like
mostly positive surveillance state in a
way there's like this widespread
intensive data collection in place just
to make sure the AIS have all the
information they need to make good
decisions and obviously the potential
negatives of this are like pretty well
explored in media and you mention them
in your story too that there's some like
political leaks of personal data for
example but overall you'll portray this
as a net benefit for people can you say
a bit more about that yeah I think it
there are definitely some downsides or
potential downsides to to the way that a
lot of data is collected in the society
but it's also sort of important to
remember that it's mostly going to these
cores which is sort of very alien and
unhuman I I find that a little more
palatable in the sense that you don't
have the Judgment associated with it
particularly if it's using the correct
type of sort of anonymized data
collection practices such as
differential privacy and so on so it's
more it's not really about me it's about
the populace as a whole yeah um
and I think as long as it's you know not
misused for political reasons or to sell
me more stuff
which you know core Central doesn't
really have an incentive to do then I I
think it's not so much like a
surveillance state but it's it's
I don't know it's more just making use
of information that's that's there and
and when I was writing this I was also
sort of implicitly assuming that this is
all all pretty much opt-in right so you
can probably just opt out of this if you
want to
interesting I would add that um whilst
we were planning and having our having
our planning meetings I I'd been just
teaching a module on privacy in my AI
ethics course and one thing that can
seem a bit dispiriting I think chatting
to some of the students on my course
some of whom are you know Educators
themselves teaching high schoolers is
that there seems to just be a declining
sense of the importance of privacy it's
really hard to get uh high schoolers at
least this is what I've I was told to
you know care about their personal
privacy when it comes to you know which
apps track them and so on you know do
you want to pay the one dollar for the
premium version of the app that doesn't
track you or get the tracking version
for free ah you know fruit nothing's
better than free I'm curious like what
what does this bring as benefits though
so we might be able to deal with the
increased privacy maybe we see it as
like a transparency State instead of a
surveillance state but how does that
connect to us being empowered in this
way and the rate of free reach sense
well I mean the the immediate obvious
benefit is that core Central has
information in order to make the best
decisions right uh that can take into
account sort of what benefits everyone
rather than just a few but also just if
you if you opt in and you get access to
more benefits from from core Central
also something then that's you know
there's there's obviously going to be
quite a lot of incentive to do that
yeah it's interesting to think of this
extreme centralization and surveillance
as a way to bring about like more
intense democracy in a way I mean you
would truly in this world be being seen
and understood by the agents responsible
for making the rules and like they would
have your best interest in mind and just
know know you and know what you needed
and and hear you yeah but equally I
think there's still the option you know
to just go into a place that doesn't
have uh you know we're not talking about
sort of cameras in every in everyone's
room for the express purpose of this
right like there's probably a camera on
your phone the same way there is now uh
there's probably more things that have
uh cameras on the say gesture
recognition but there's no sort of Big
Brother style you know uh two-way TV in
every room that's sort of monitoring
your every move I think it's just about
using the data that you do get sort of
more naturally more efficiently yeah
so you're describing this world as very
unified but not necessarily
overbearingly surveilled
um there is in 2045 one of the last
beats of your story this Grand
unification that basically kind of calls
for one planet one people I was curious
with core Central already involved in
every country's Affairs like what does
this actually do for the world how does
this shift things
I mean in many ways it's it's
not quite symbolic my intuition here is
is it that would it would be this
similar to if say the EU now were to
federalize right in in many ways a lot
of the leg work is done in terms of just
the the intertwining of the economies
and you know building up a sort of solid
cultural Foundation right and that
people are more willing to take that
final sort of push towards unification
well this isn't in controversial in your
world you also do mention like in your
short story one of them you say that
there are people who are arguing against
integration and they're kind of fighting
to have their own independent local AI
systems that are less intelligent but
not a part of this whole core Central
thing what do you see happening to like
this part of the world some years down
the road like are they still
dissatisfied and is there room for them
to find purchase or do they kind of die
out I ideally whatever is causing this
desire would be sort of addressed and
fixed right
um but at the same time you can't make
everyone happy all of the time and even
within sort of locks like the EU or in
individual countries there are often
like secessionist movements and I think
that isn't something that we can just
magically fix with intelligent Ai and
yeah I mean this is almost a problem for
further down the road for core Central
and the government
yeah I guess I would add that sort of
one of the things that I really
appreciated once I started reading you
have really good science fiction uh not
just not the more basic stuff is that a
lot of a lot of the simplable stuff like
Star Trek presents a world in which
everyone just agrees with each other
about my stuff the human human conflict
just kind of magically drops off the
scene and then you know reading stuff
like uh Hyperion or uh the expanse books
you realize that you know like no people
still have different religious beliefs
people still have different political
values people still have different
National values and they're not going to
magically drop away so I think yeah
those conflicts will will remain and
finding better ways to navigate them is
part of the push towards centralization
yeah I'm also curious what some of your
biggest sources of inspiration were when
you were working on this together
so for me personally I uh came
relatively late relatively recently to e
m Banks's culture novels
um which I think
one of the rare examples of pretty
optimistic sci-fi
um and I was astonished when I came
across them that like some of them were
written in the 80s and yet he gives
really sophisticated uh portrayals of
what AGI could look like and how AI can
coexist alongside
extension biological beings in a
relatively benign fashion without sort
of being afraid of exploring you know
what what use do sort of like relatively
cognitively constrained biological
beings have in a world of like 4 000 IQ
Minds the size of small moons and I
found that such an exciting inspiring
source of literature so that was one big
source for me in other words I'm a huge
fan of the expanse uh the show and and
the books obviously that's that's kind
of semi-dystopian but I mean one of the
uh things it does really well is it it's
a very politically messy World
um yeah something you don't often see in
sci-fi so you know Star Wars has this
relatively clean division the good guys
bad guys Star Trek um has again the
Federation usually seems like this
pretty monolithic entity but the idea
that you know there are all these
complex factions constantly kind of
battling together or arguing or
presenting different perspectives that's
something that I think is seeing in a
lot of good Sci-Fi and a lot of sort of
speculative fiction so I was um really
Keen to sort of integrate some of that
kind of social messiness social and
political messiness into the world
yeah I mean I also have to Echo uh in M
Banks is the culture series as pretty
inspirational I mean that Series has
been something that shaped my view of AI
as a whole not just for this world
building competition but for the sort of
the way that I would like to see things
go I really appreciate you both talking
through all this with me it's really
great to get a little background view of
all this fascinating material that your
group has put together
I'm looking forward to hearing Lara's
perspective next as we discuss some of
the potential impacts of this work
you've done yeah it's been fun chatting
oh it's been great fun
[Music]
with the team this big it's impossible
to really do justice to all the people
who contributed we weren't able to
feature Jessica Bieber Catherine or
Clarissa but we did get a chance to
catch up with one other member with
incredibly relevant expertise and that's
laramani Lara is a research associate at
the center for the study of existential
risk and she's actually done research
into how to most effectively communicate
about global catastrophic risks so I was
really curious to hear her thoughts on
this world and also what she thought
about the kind of creative aspirational
yet grounded World building that flies
competition encouraged overall
hi Laura great to have you with us uh
thanks for having me
so before we dive into your expertise on
communication I'd love to hear your
thoughts on one of the major themes in
your world that I've been discussing
with John and Henry and that's
centralization so like in 2045 your
world has this vote for a single world
government and I'm just curious how you
feel about that is that something you'd
celebrate or something you'd be kind of
concerned about if you were living in
this world can I with the framing of
having the most optimistic world
or building hopeful Futures as as the
competition had
um I think it is a really nice kind of
goal to aim for that you have this this
kind of unified approach how realistic
it is
I don't know but uh but we definitely
strive to keep in there as well um
elements of equality and inclusion
around different uh kind of communities
and voices
um and that's where our world has these
kind of sub cores
um so it has the core Central but then
has sub cores that are designed to kind
of meet with more Community level need
yeah so it sounds like that was kind of
one way of addressing a risk which would
come along with us of you know reducing
diversity or having some kind of strong
armed power structure across all
different kinds of people is that like
the main sort of concern that people
were pushing back with as you were
thinking about the centralization
yeah I think we were really
um concerned about
keeping out this kind of homogenized
approach to thinking about the way in
which it might function our kind of core
Central might function and the fact that
the needs of of one region may be vastly
different from another and trying to
ensure that that gets encapsulated in
those discussions yeah
well I'd love to hear about your own
work with communication so you've you've
developed a role-playing and
scenario-based exercises to help
communicate Global catastrophic risks
I'd love to hear a little bit about what
those look like and how their efficacy
compares to more traditional
Communications techniques
this whole kind of world of experiential
engagement with risk is something I'm
just really passionate about and it's
it's kind of filtered that throughout my
career and has kind of culminated with
my work at Caesar looking at this for
Global catastrophic risk and so one of
the the first things I did in this space
was to bring together as many people
working with scenario based exercises
across all the different risk domains
within Global catastrophic risk to
basically come together
and talk about what we're doing
why we're choosing to do it that way
what works well and how can we improve
um and I think we still have a bit of a
long way to go in understanding what is
truly effective
because I think a scenario-based
exercise is very much
um
its impact is dependent on how well it's
tailored to to its its need and its its
audience so everybody approaches
scenarios differently so
um there are very simple kind of Matrix
type scenarios where you test two
variables against each other and you can
come up with four very different
scenarios
but I prefer this kind of more creative
side to scenarios so we have one that's
really well established within the
center which is a role-playing game that
explores um AI safety and ethics
features
um and it's called intelligence Rising
we've been doing that for about three
years now and this is just a really
interesting game and something that's
just really captured my imagination for
the last few years
it's a it's a scenario in the fact that
you play uh either the head of a nation
state or you play the head of a company
an AI Tech development company
and you work through this world along
with the game master and every single
game has a different narrative that
emerges a different future that's told
which is really exciting but what's
really unique about intelligence Rising
as a game is that we ask the players to
embody that character they're not just
forecasting or Futures thinking
in a in a scenario that actually asked
to play that character as if they're
right there in there as if they're the
ones making that decision so you get
this additional kind of embodiment of of
the risk itself I really love this kind
of uh realm of scenarios and features
building and and thinking about uh yeah
features and risk in a more creative
kind of way and I think scenario based
exercises can really help us do that
I mean there's still and I said that
earlier there's still a little bit of a
way to go with this and we've seen this
pre-covered there were many kind of
sorry based exercises used for pandemic
prevention or pandemic preparedness and
you know what happens is the people that
run them come out with a whole host of
recommendations and suggestions on how
you can better improve or prepare for
such a risk
and that's where they stay they don't
they quite frequently don't get adopted
into policy yeah and there's still this
gap between us doing something like this
and making sure that it has an impact on
on the way in which we we prepare for
those risks so that's why we're working
quite extensively at the moment is to
try and think about how we can bridge
this Gap and kind of work to work to
improve that for sure one of the goals
of this overall effort at fli is to try
to help creative thinkers to see how
they can have a valuable impact on the
future with their work and also how to
get technical thinkers to realize that
storytelling is valuable so it's so cool
to hear you talking about how this
embodiment and this creative engagement
really seems to help people you know get
to richer and more interesting
narratives do you have any advice for
like how filmmakers or other creators
might be able to help bridge this Gap
I'm a massive believer in the the power
of creatives
um and I try to embed creatives in as
much of my work as possible
so for example last year in September we
had a Creative Communications Workshop
that we hosted at Caesar and we had a
whole range of creatives come in so that
included people that worked on on
narratives that included um the board
game designer matiaminipase who designed
pandemic we had a trapeze artist we we
had a museum curator from the art
science museum in Singapore and we had
people that deal with very specific kind
of Arts like thermochronic paint which
is paint that changes color with
temperature
and when you've got them all to come in
and we invited a whole host of academics
or people that worked within the space
of existential risk and we got them to
sit together and think about ways
creative ways in which we could
communicate risk and this was just
really fantastic even though I was one
of the people behind designing something
like this I was really quite stunned by
thinking about New Media as a way to
kind of communicate some of these risks
I think there's just so many ways to
kind of bring creativity in what we do
but I think it's important to not kind
of put creativity in a box and say oh
those are creatives like you know they
can come in and kind of help us I don't
know draw our conferences or things like
this that's one way to use it but
creatives think about risk in a
different way and they're able to frame
it in a way in a different way I think
all different people from all different
backgrounds have different ways of
thinking about risk and thinking about
uh you know these kind of themes and
it's really important that you cover all
of those because you know not everyone
in the if you're going to communicate
risk you have to speak to all sorts of
different uh different voices too so the
more voices that you have in the
designing and the and the development of
of communications helps with the the
dissemination and the yeah so say say
I'm a person who's like fairly Technical
and not as creative if I have some some
concern that I'm really worried about
existential risk wise maybe and I want
people to be worried about it too how
would you advise that I try to find
creative thinkers or push my own
thinking in more creative way to kind of
get in this direction and reach more
people yeah that's a really interesting
one and you know a lot of the stuff that
we've been able to do is because we have
that extensive network or people that
have worked with different people or
kind of known them through that kind of
Base
um and we've done it through all sorts
of different different means we've
approached them um creatives and just
said I really like your style and I
would really love it if you would think
about this kind of work with us or is it
something that might interest you
some people have really taken to it and
have really tried to help us through
different creative means of developing
cartoons or things like this other
people have been more skeptical
and there's certainly something in there
about the skill sets that you have
um you know there's it's a very fine
line to tread when you're talking about
risks that have this potential Fear
Factor around them and carefully
navigating that in and being quite
sensitive to that too but I think you'll
find that there's already people that
are already interested in these topics
uh and that would be would be Keen to
team up so going back to that kind of
like Fear Factor and fear versus hope
how did those kind of play off of each
other when you were thinking about
designing this world that you helped to
create
so challenging
when we started this world building
contest
it was the first time bearing in mind
when you know we work at the center of
the study of existential risk and the
center for teacher of intelligence you
know places that think about risk
it was one of the first times that uh
you know some of us had ever tried to
think optimistically about these
features
amazing what did they do like what did
that feel like was was that it was
really it was really tough it was really
challenging because for so long we
thought about all the problems that
might arise or the different you know
the different Pathways to get there and
then suddenly trying to think quite
optimistically about it one it was quite
refreshing it was like oh this is quite
fun yeah this oh the potential that is
here and it kind of opens up these new
kind of Pathways to new messages that we
might have around the way in which we
talk about these risks
um but I guess like we it was it was
hard to to still be really optimistic
and I think we still held back somewhat
for quite a large amount of the process
until we really felt that we were like
you know we started to relax a little
more into it and and kind of be a little
bit more
um optimistic and hopeful about it
um but it was it was really exciting for
I think the whole team I think we really
enjoyed um for once being challenged
to be more optimistic about about the
Futures in the space yeah it was really
good fun
awesome
do you think that this kind of more
optimistic balancing of Hope alongside
risk is something that would be good to
have more of in kind of Pop Culture
stories about the future
yeah I'm a big I'm a big fan of using
hope in messaging and I think that's
something that that comes across quite
interestingly across some of the the
kind of academic literature in the space
so
um I'm in Cotton Barrett and Toby ORD
coined that phrase of existential hope
as a message of kind of um you know you
don't always talk about the negatives
but let's also talk about the positives
um and it's something that I think can
counteract things like the Fear Factor
and count and can kind of get people a
little bit more motivated and so I think
it is really important to have the
balance between talking about risk but
also talking about the positive benefits
and I think it's it's not like doing one
or the other I think there's a way to
package the way in which you talk about
those it encompasses both of those
that's why I loved this world building
contest I was so Keen to be involved
because for me it was one of the first
times I'd ever tried to write hopeful
messages or write hopeful features and
that would just felt like a really
powerful thing that we could do yeah and
John and Henry uh told me that you were
kind of instrumental in bringing
everyone together to create this so
thanks so much for for doing that labor
to kind of get everyone in the room and
get the conversation started and I
really appreciate the world that
resulted yeah I was just yeah when I saw
the competition
um I was like okay this this time it's
time for us to do something like this
one it feeds like just into lost the
communication work that we've been doing
but also so you know it's that thing
always we'll be working in the pandemic
in you know setting in our home offices
as well and a really nice way to bring
all sorts of different kind of skill
sets across the across the teams
together and apply it to one problem or
one kind of project together and you
know I got to work with uh you know
people that I don't normally work with
so you know John and Henry are mainly on
that AI side and I don't really work
that as much on the AI side so getting
to work with them was really great along
with other people across the center the
two centers that you know I wouldn't
normally engage with so fun well thank
you so much for for all the work that
you put into this thank you for taking
the time to chat with us about this
process
no worries thanks so much for having me
[Music]
if this podcast has got you thinking
about the future you can find out more
about this world and explore the ideas
contained in the other worlds at
www.worldbuild.ai we want to hear your
thoughts are these worlds you'd want to
live in
if you've enjoyed this episode and would
like to help more people discover and
discuss these ideas you can give us a
rating or leave a comment wherever
you're listening to this podcast to read
all the comments and appreciate every
rating this podcast is produced and
edited by worldview studio and the
future of Life Institute fli is a
non-profit that works to reduce
large-scale risks from transformative
Technologies and promote the development
and use of these Technologies to benefit
all life on Earth we run educational
Outreach and grants programs and
advocate for better policy making in the
United Nations U.S government and
European Union institutions if you're a
Storyteller working on Films or other
creative projects about the future we
can also help you understand the science
and storytelling potential of
transformative Technologies
if you'd like to get in touch with us or
any of the teams featured on the podcast
to collaborate you can email World build
futureoflife.org
a reminder this podcast explores the
ideas created as part of fli's World
building contest and our hope is that
this series Sparks discussion about the
kinds of Futures we all want
the ideas we discuss here are not to be
taken as fli positions
you can find more about our work at
www.futureoflife.org or subscribe to our
newsletter to get updates on all our
projects
thanks for listening to imagine a world
stay tuned to explore more positive
futures
[Music]